welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we're going to be breaking down the new
Netflix film the platform the high
concept movie has a lot to unpack from
it and in the wake of what's currently
going on in the world the film feels
extremely relevant throughout this video
we're going to be discussing the ins and
outs of the movie's plot its ending and
the real meaning behind it there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to catch the movie yet and
don't want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day and please
click the thumbs up if you enjoy it with
all that out of the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of the platform okay so the
platform has several metaphors about
society with there being clear comments
about class warfare the platform is set
in a dystopian future in which resources
are short and clearly the structures of
civilization are failing we follow gang
a member of a prison called the pit that
is made up of 333 levels
goring has voluntarily entered the
prison in order to get a degree but he
soon realizes that he signed up for more
than he bargained for on each level
other than zero there are two prisoners
placed in the cell and a platform of
food that descends from the top
downwards level zero is the location of
the privileged and they create the food
and thus the economy of the pit the
platform remains on each level for two
minutes and in that time the prisoners
can eat food from the table if the
levels above you eat too much then you
will likely starve and the movie very
much centers around the aesthetic that
those higher up on the chain get to live
lavishly whilst those further down must
feed upon the scraps the film very much
carries the message that if everyone
only took what they needed and there
would be enough for all however as I'm
sure you can guess the majority of the
people on the levels are very
self-centered and thus they tend to
overindulge whenever they get the
opportunity it's a motif that is
extremely relevant to our times and this
movie definitely struck a chord with me
after seeing the the crazy panic buying
of toilet paper recently that was a
situation in which many people took more
than they needed and thus because of
this greed we've been left with
shortages so the more vulnerable members
of society
left with very little this film is very
much about how greed and being
self-centered can often lead to the
downfall of others even if unintentional
take for example Evangeline Lilly who
was recently refused to self isolate
because she says she values the freedom
of life that's fine and I'm sure we
would alter to love to go running
through the hills but the reason that
people are locking themselves away right
now isn't because they're worried about
dying from the disease it's because if
they get it they could pass it on to
others who will die from it and this
selfish attitude is putting people at
risk
this self-centered thought process is
what has led to a pandemic and now
because of it everyone is worse off I
don't want to get too preachy as
everyone has the right to do what they
want but the movie is definitely about
the thoughtful versus the thoughtless
and how even just a handful of the
latter can have a knock-on effect most
of the prisoners in this movie start off
very wide-eyed however due to the
situations that they're put in and the
greed of others they end up becoming
greedy themselves the prisoners changed
levels and do so every month and we
initially start with Kerrang being
partnered with a man named Reema gassy
all prisoners are allowed to bring one
item in with them from the outside and
tremor gassy has brought in a self
sharpening knife which he was pretty
much tricked into buying this
exemplifies his personality and how he
will always try and keep ahead of others
even if it means he loses out eventually
he's a cruel man who spits on food just
a lord at over those below him and is
very much someone that will climb up the
rope and then pull it up with them this
is because he views society is tricking
him into hedging his bets on one thing
and then making him realize that it was
all a scam he killed an illegal
immigrant by throwing a TV out of a
window and anger after he was fooled and
he refuses to take responsibility for
the things that he's done he only gives
grain what he gets in return
information-wise tries to take ownership
of the word obviously and won't even let
Goren come to his side of the room it's
very petty stuff and it does showcase
how certain members of society act the
food in the pit could be rationed out
fairly but trimmer gas II would rather
have the opportunity to potentially get
more one day even though we know that
this is a trick to keep those who are
truly empowered constantly above him
there are comments on communism and the
movie definitely paints out the message
that if things were more equal than we
would live in a fairer society however
trimmer gassy doesn't wish for this as
he does not view those around him as
equal because he wants the opportunity
to get more this never really works out
for him though and there are times where
he has to resort to things like
cannibalism in order to potentially get
to a higher level when if things were
fairer he would be fine every single
month he's basically that guy at work
that you start off with you know the one
then they became a supervisor and it
completely changed the way they act you
know the guy I think he's called Steven
but but he's got a lisp so he's called
even now because of the outbreak that
were in my friend was actually given a
month at home to do work however for
some reason the people that had to
remain on site said that it wasn't fair
that his department were going to be off
so now he has to go back to work
even though the people who made an
uproar will have to be in anyway they
made things worse for others even though
they didn't have to because they viewed
things as being unfair it speaks to
human behavior and how he will often try
to bring down others with us similar to
this tremor gasps he has very little
power so the power that he does get has
completely corrupted him and he uses it
to crap on others those above him will
never accept him but he's driven so much
by his own ego that he sees himself as
powerful and thus he becomes a figure of
hate juxtaposing this gang rises
throughout the film and this is
exemplified in his choice of his item
which is the book Don Quixote in that a
nobleman goes through so much to to the
splendor that he receives that he loses
his mind and ends up becoming a knight
that serves the community instead of
himself that's a real top-level view of
it but the book is very much exemplified
in Greg's journey he's criticized for
doing this and represents the academic
not having first-hand experience of what
they're talking about but it does
eventually provide him with the
knowledge of how to help others Greg
initially starts off refusing to eat the
food but of course hunger gets the
better of him and he ends up giving into
the system much in the same way that my
wife ended up buying 900 toilet rolls
because everyone else did one day
another prison in Miharu come
down on the platform searching for a
child it's believed that this is a son
but as we get into the movie we discover
that this isn't true she's an immigrant
and because of this she falls into the
other tree magazi villain ices her with
lies and you get the sense that he
blames her for the way things are rather
than realizing that it's a system at
fault and not her society dumps on her
and even when she stands up for herself
she's further detested in this first
month Greg makes the most of what he has
worth through magazi and his lip service
paid to the latter believing in God this
month because he's had a good one this
kind of reminded me of when actors and
sports stars gain awards and they thank
God for it
when they lose they don't blame God for
making them lose so yeah it was a nice
little line that shows human psychology
anyway they both wake up on level 1 7 1
which is the lowest one that tree magazi
has ever been on and because of this he
pulls the drastic measure of tying
goring up in order to eat him when the
platform comes down with no food he
blames those above and calls them
animals for not leaving anything however
he did the same he purges Greg's flash
in order to make him taste better and
Gio says he's about to start the long
and agonizing process of eating him
Miharu comes down and rescues him goring
resorts to eating trimmer gassy and he
learns perspective on what it is to be
as desperate as the man before him
showing that being less judgmental to
others is very important as you don't
know what they've been through he wakes
up in a cell on level 33 with EMU Gary
who was an interviewer for the pit she's
been diagnosed with terminal cancer and
is wracked with guilt for being part of
the system after sending so many to hell
she's decided to join them to try and
help she represents the higher up
feeling remorseful for their privilege
and actually sacrifices herself in order
to help Greg initially she talks to the
prisoners below about rationing but they
don't listen this showcases those in
positions of power using their voices to
try and influence those below gal gadot
recently did a video in which
celebrities sang imagine by John Lennon
and it was meant to show that we're all
in this together
however as you probably know this didn't
go down well celebrities due to their
privilege on in the desperate situations
that others are in and thus sending
thoughts and prayers it does very little
similar to that video what the words
McGary fall on deaf ears and Gaurang is
forced into making threats that change
things he threatens to defecate on the
food if they don't listen and thus the
ones below do but the ones above don't
because they have no threat to them thus
we can take from this that the power
structure of kindness must start from
the top all this adds to a really
engaging film and it's certainly one of
the most unique metaphors of society
structure and how things are set up
Miharu arrives on the platform and they
save her but she kills a mcGarry's dog
and though she sent back down
Emma Geary says that the woman is an
actress and her prejudices get the
better of her she says that she
interviewed her and as she didn't have a
child with her at the time in McGary
brandishes a liar
upon waking up on level 2 or 2 we
realized that emu Gary has killed
herself in order to give something for
going to feed upon there our last supper
metaphors as well as her and trimmer
gases ghosts acting as angels and devils
on his shoulder after surviving an
arduous month he wakes up in a cell with
a man named baharat who brought a Robin
with him in order to climb up but those
above don't let him ascend this could
have destroyed the pair however the two
decide to ride the lift down rushing of
the food to the cells they've put their
differences in race attitude and
background aside and thus there's a
positive outcome this shows that when we
work together instead of divided we can
survive and get by though this rationing
is initially hated by the masses after
proving it works in convincing those
through the process they send a message
to level zero they initially think of
the best way to do this is through
protecting a perfect dessert and sending
it back up which shows that when we bond
we can showcase that things can change
through the descent they see people
coveting money their possessions and
anything they can even though it's
completely pointless to the predicament
that they're in upon arriving at the
bottom they discover mejores child who
is actually shown to be a girl
showcasing how things get twisted and
changed when we do not know the full
story
they give the desert to her to eat
cementing that she carries the message
with her after baharat dies meringue
puts the child on the platform and it
travels back up to the top this cements
that it is possible to teach the
children of our future that there are
other ways to do things and that they
must not become trapped into the same
routines as us those higher up believe
that no one will
sixteen was in the pit and they enforced
these lies perhaps to free themselves of
guilt
however this showcases that there were
indeed younger people suffering and they
would likely go on to grow up and become
trapped in the same systems if we are
able to teach those going forward and
not to fall victim to the same mistakes
as we did then there will be progression
that will eventually elevate us all it
shows us that we can use our actions and
words to let the higher up to know that
things must change
however we too must be willing to make
sacrifices in order to achieve this and
the bottom
göran goes off with the ghost of prema
cassie showing that the old ways have
died and it is possible that there can
be a new way of thinking now before we
get into the review I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with the chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the film in the
comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of April and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part now what did I think of
the movie overall well whilst I
definitely don't think that the platform
is for everyone those who appreciate
films that have a lot of social
commentary in will definitely that this
up was a lot going on and it carries a
powerful message with it the movie is
well acted and presented and it stands
is probably the best Netflix original
this year due to the times that we
currently live in I feel like the
platform is extremely relevant and
should definitely be something that
people check out even if they don't
agree with all of the key themes the
platform is great and I think it will be
a big talking point going forward it's a
movie that stuck with me long after
watching it and because of that it gets
a 9 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the platform and what you
took from a movie comment below and let
me know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out a breakdown of Westworld
season 3 episode 1 which is going to be
linked at the end if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it there's a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at Definition
YT or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
you